what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so heaven this cold sucks but the
show must go on so we are covering the
aftermath to the Oz effect which in
truth really kind of starts the doctor
like the mystery of dr. Manhattan which
is really kind of cool because one of
the things that's going on with regards
to the Doomsday Clock story is Superman
meeting dr. Manhattan that's really
gonna be like one of the great big huge
things that happens but one of the big
questions people have is how do we get
to that point how do we get to the point
where by Superman meets dr. Manhattan
well of course a lot of that's unfolding
in the Doomsday Clock story but what
this also does is sort of grab Superman
in DC rebirth as a whole and begin the
process of trying to chase after
Manhattan and figure out what's going on
now the cool thing about this is that
this initially picks up in the immediate
aftermath of the AHS effect now in that
story we of course learned that mr. oz
was jor-el the father of Superman and
this had two major ramifications the
first was the fact that the father of
Superman was alive which of course was
believed to have be virtually impossible
because of the fact that Krypton was
destroyed now what we found out in the
oz effect was that someone presumably
dr. Manhattan had grabbed jor-el the
moment before Krypton's destruction
basically altered the past of Krypton
itself and then kept jor-el alive and
transported him on earth so really a
kind of brings an to fray a lot of the
actions of Manhattan himself which is to
say according to the traditional history
of the DC universe jor-el died on
Krypton when it blew up but because the
actions of Manhattan with the Watchmen
being rolled over into DC rebirth
instead of those events transpiring the
way they always did
Manhattan save jor-el now we don't know
why we know jor-el interpretation which
was basically to show you know jewelry
that humanity was not worth saving and
that Superman trying to save people from
themselves was a fool's fool's errand
and so the result was to try to swindle
Superman try to get him to walk away
from earth form a New Krypton and then
just repopulate the Kryptonian race more
or less it was interesting because what
this does is a sort of throw Superman
into this existential crisis for years
and years and years Superman always knew
there were like absolute factors in his
life he always knew his father died his
mother died he always knew he was the
last Son of Krypton until Kara zor-el
came back and then realized you know
that his cousin was a survivor of
Krypton it was always the idea that him
and Lois Lane are meant to be together
they have kids or they have a son that
that kind of stuff you know but like
these cornerstones of Superman's life is
all predicated on the fact that there's
no going back there's
way for him to basically reconnect with
his parents but to suddenly have his
father thrown back into his life and
then basically be told his father became
a villain and his father was saved by
some sort of being out there of
incalculable power suddenly throws the
entire life of Superman into disarray to
take Superman and it makes him very
human because he responds the exact same
way that we would when he basically goes
through and starts reconnecting or
rebuilding the kelex robot form from
from Krypton one of the first questions
yes here is who's your master the
response is jor-el who is mr. Oz the
response draw out this is DC confirming
the fact that it wasn't a red herring
mr. Oz was definitively jor-el and so if
that's the case then Superman now has to
come face-to-face with the fact that
it's entirely possible that one his
father survived the destruction of
Krypton and two his father became a bad
guy and his father became a bad guy what
does that say about him because all of
his understanding although Superman's
understanding about the world stems from
a combination of what he learned from
the Kent's and what moral compasses his
parents gave him through the various
Holograms and so on and so forth that he
interfaced with over the course of his
life and now again this is a really cool
moment because in the middle of all this
he suddenly met by the arrival of Batman
now of course the fact that Batman
showed up without Superman realizing it
is really just designed to show us how
distracted Superman is that he easily
should have overheard you know Batman's
arrival just by virtue of his
super-hearing and the bat jet and so on
and so forth but notice this Batman
Begins dropping these little things
basically saying hey look there's
something wrong with ton I came here
because I'm a friend I came here because
I'm concerned for you but it's not just
you jor-el coming back it's not just you
I encountered my own father someone
somewhere has messed with Todd this all
goes back to DC universe number one the
one shot that set the whole DC rebirth
landscape in motion this goes back to
the button when weary Alan Andrew Swain
ended up traveling to the flashpoint
universe which we thought had been
destroyed all these things are going on
you know all these things are hitting
home to the idea that someone somewhere
is screwing with things now one of the
biggest indications of what this is and
how this impacts Superman in the middle
of Superman
talking to his wife and trying to
understand what's going on you know even
questioning the fact as to whether or
not he's a good father because of the
fact that his life is in such a state of
disarray he's suddenly met by Hal Jordan
who basically says look we may be able
to give you an answer to the question
that you're searching for of course
Superman races off meets with Hal Jordan
and the Green
Lanterns home base of Mogo and what they
do is they show him a kind of like a
recorded footage record a database of
Krypton's destruction what it basically
shows is how Krypton was obliterated you
know the fact that you know the planet
just sort of exploded and that was
really about it but it also shows his
rocket being fired off from the planet
and his parents last-ditch effort to
basically keep one of their race alive
but before we see what happens next
before we end up seeing jor-el being
saved or something like that
suddenly the video feed is scrambled
meaning somebody tampered with it or the
eventual like the actual event itself
was kind of screwed up and what this
seems to indicate is exactly what jor-el
said that somewhere in those final
moments when Krypton was about to be
destroyed what everything was about to
end someone reached in grabbed him and
kept him alive that person is clearly
dr. Manhattan that's what seems to be
going on here but again there's no
definitive information given here this
whole idea of Manhattan somehow
intervening this whole idea of Manhattan
being involved in here is also Coke and
dagger because all the clues point to
him but nothing says it's him and that's
what's so cool about this because we
know it's him we know it's Manhattan
there's no reason for it not to be in
this moment Superman says well the only
way for me to definitively know for sure
the only way for me to actually know
what it was it happened to my father
when Krypton was basically destroyed is
to go back and to see Krypton when it
was destroyed so traveling to the
Justice League Watchtower what he ends
up doing is tracking down the cosmic
treadmill now the cosmic treadmill is
basically the treadmill flash uses to
run back and forth through Tommy oh
really just kind of a way for him to
traverse the entire landscape now
depending on what era of stories you're
reading from the flash it really kind of
varies the cosmic treadmill was
something that was used way back in the
Silver Age again it was the memes of
Barry Allen used to travel back and
forth through time we've seen stories
where he's done that without using the
cosmic treadmill he can just run fast
enough to break the time barrier so
really kind of depends on what area
you're really pointy to this is kind of
a throwback and it really sort of points
the finger back to like 1950s flash
comics but it is still pretty cool
because Superman needs it right like
this is not Silver Age Superman for the
1950s and 60s he can't do anything he
wants to you know he can't just travel
back in time and all that kooky stuff he
needs to use a cosmic treadmill which is
cool because what this does is it allows
him to use the treadmill and run all the
way back to Krypton itself basically run
back however many thousands of years to
the point at which Krypton was you know
at its height and then basically find
that
we're Krypton was going to be destroyed
and then figure out what in the world
went on possibly even same as Paris the
process but noticed this this could
potentially have massive ramifications
for the whole idea of the DC DC
landscape River this is what happened
with flashpoint what you're seeing right
here this is what started new 52 Barry
Allen went back in time and saved his
mom's life only to find out that
everything happened differently from the
way it was supposed to he had to go back
in time and let her die in order for
things to be preserved in order for
everything to return to a state of
normalcy
Superman is making this exact same
mistake but in order to try to stop
Superman from doing this what we end up
finding out is the moment in which he
vanishes basically we end up having the
arrival of Booster Gold who shows up
from the future to try to stop Superman
to keep the entire universe from
collapsing into itself as a result of
whatever it is that he ends up doing but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]